it's morning in the Kalahari and this
female cheetah has discovered that her
cubs are growing ever more independent
she calls for them but they've already
gone out exploring and they've
discovered a wounded gemsbok that may
have escaped from a lion its weak but
something tells them they're still out
of their league
they're intrigued but they don't know
what to do its horns could be lethal
it's too big even for their mother to
tackle eventually their curiosity
satisfied a he their mother and leave
the gemsbok to its fate young male
cheetahs like these often team up
together
whereas female cheetahs live solitary
lives unless they have Cubs these two
were probably brothers and partners for
life
they hunt go courting and today they're
exploring together the cheetah cubs have
gone out hunting without their mother
and have come across a herd of gemsbok
and the hunt is on
they've caught a cap but they're about
to find out that like their own mother
the calf's mother is fierce when her
offspring are threatened
she's desperate to free her youngster
from the cheetahs strangling bite
the calf seems none the worse for its
adventure and its mother turns her
attention again to the Cheetahs
the CAF had a lucky escape but the
cheetahs have been fortunate as well
gemsbok horns are deadly weapons the cow
could so easily have killed them when
the cheetah cubs are about 18 months old
they're old enough to leave their mother
and seek their own fortunes once they go
she may never see them again